resucitado en las aguas del Atlántico y
antojó nuevamente tierra Este viernes lo
hizo como huracán de categoría 1 en
Carolina del Sur las rachas de viento
llegaron a alcanzar los 140 kilómetros
por hora sin embargo su contacto con
Tierra Firme lo debilitó y pasó a
convertirse en ciclón tropical
los dientes más fuertes ocurrirán esta
noche en el área de los tres condados
del norte de charleston a través de
gramstrong posiblemente vean ráfagas de
viento de entre 120 y 140 kilómetros por
hora y de 80 a 112 kilómetros por hora
tierra adentro Mientras tanto los ojos
de la Unión Americana continúan en la
devastación que el huracán de categoría
4 Causa en Florida
he ordenado que se tomen todas las
medidas posibles para salvar vidas y
ayudar a los sobrevivientes porque cada
minuto cuenta no solo una crisis para
Florida Esta es una crisis
estadounidense apenas estamos comenzando
a ver la escala de esa destrucción Es
probable que se clasifique entre
proveedores de la nación y entre en los
peores de la historia ustedes vieron las
escenas en la televisión casas y
propiedades arrasadas la reconstrucción
llevará meses años
aseguró que el Gobierno Federal cubrirá
Los costos de la limpieza de escombros
un paso clave para iniciar el proceso de
recuperación a pesar de la destrucción
los floridanos no pierden la esperanza
todo el mundo está cansado todo el mundo
está estresado sin agua corriente sin
electricidad todo el mundo está tratando
de trabajar en todo pero tienes que
seguir moviéndote y hacer lo que haces
todo está mal en este momento pero lo
superaremos
hasta el momento se contabilizan más de
una veintena de muertes en la Península
al menos 1,8 millones de negocios y
casas particulares continuaban sin
electricidad este viernes